as it turns out
america's getting dumb not just america
the youth is really profoundly
dumb in many cases so you watch this i
want you to laugh but i also want you to
cry i want simultaneous emotions on this
let's take a listen it's fantastic it's
new york city by the way that's times
square let's take a listen
you got volume
let's see yeah
somewhere somewhere oh here we go here
we go
originally
um
i definitely don't know no give me give
me your best guess i guess a country
what is a country again do you know what
country the panama canal is in
no if you have to guess like what do you
think it sounds like it's a country
europe
yes do you know how many moons the earth
has
around how many if you had to guess
two
yes do you know what time this is
5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40 45
245
yes do you know what country the great
role of china is in
country yeah
if you had to guess
japanese
yes do you know what the third month of
each year is
ain't that leap year or some [ __ ]
yeah do you know what 15 percent of 100
is
[ __ ] around what it is if you have to
guess
probably like 75 i don't know
yes can you name all the months
september january february march april
may june july august
yes do you know what seven plus seven
plus seven is
28
no no i'm bugging um 14
plus seven
i don't know what do we call a shape
with five sides
[Music]
is it an octagon wait that's six
that's eight octagon is eight
is it a stop sign
you call it a stop sign didn't you so
tyler we laugh we laugh it is funny you
have to let yourself laugh in life
because honestly life's just too short
not to laugh but terrifying that's real
footage
and he has a bunch of those you can go
and you can watch this over and over
it's not like oh he really had to work
hard to get 10 people
it's everywhere
everywhere
so you all laugh when i say abolish the
department of education but you know
it's true because those kids are
probably in school coming out and they
don't even know i mean come on somebody
says to you and the best part is when
they say she doesn't even say japan she
says japanese about the great wall of
china it says the great wall of china
of china is in the sentence
so here's my points on this number one i
think it's important to do these these
men on the streets because you have to
expose what's going on right you can't
just me sitting here and saying oh the
dumbing down of america it just doesn't
translate the same way as you see oh wow
these people are dumb and you have to be
able to say dumb i don't want to hear
like oh you're hating on you know the
intellectually challenged i'm not gonna
say the intellectually challenged dumb
is dumb this is dumb these people are
not properly educated so here's my issue
number one
what's going on with education what is
going on with education
are they getting an education at all
what does it look like what schools did
they go to can we now have a
conversation about government-funded
schools can we now have a conversation
about why you need vouchers and why you
need
competition injected into the
marketplace because otherwise your end
product looks like that you don't need
to send your kids to school parents to
come out and they can't tell you where
the great wall of china is
okay and they answer japanese
okay
some of those kids i don't know do they
go to college high school i mean these
are older
individuals in some cases
okay
secondly
where are the parents
education does not stop begin and end
with school
so where are they are there no
conversations happening at home about
anything truthfully think about how much
you learn at school right how much
you're supposed to learn at school i
should say but all of that
actually
continues or sometimes even starts
at home around the dinner table
you're always i'm always reading with my
son
i'm always talking about shapes and
colors and you know observing what we
see outside and oh that's this and you
know animals and so what what is going
on at home are there absentee parents we
always talk about that too
absentee parents is there not
are parents not invested in in their
kids at home are these kids now that are
just staring at a phone all day
and they're not interacting with the
world they're not asking questions
because they're like this all day what's
going on what's broken it goes beyond
the educational system
the other thing is the media
this is the kardashian culture
right this is
reality television brain dead tv now
don't get me wrong i like some brain
dead tv i do i like to sit sometimes and
have that hour i watch the bachelor i
enjoy every minute listen if you're
going to put yourself into that shitty
situation i get to laugh at you that's
it and i watch it and i sit and i have i
have my little snack oftentimes not
popcorn but you know you you know the
drill have my little snack and i enjoy
every minute of it but that's not all
i'm doing i'm doing a bunch of research
for the show i'm reading constantly
that's my like hour
escape away that's my not i call it my
my numbing hour
are these kids are these young adults in
a constant state of mind numbing
everything is this all they're consuming
now something's wrong here man
i mean and you know we do laugh like i
said you laugh at that those first
images you left this but then
in a second you catch yourself and
you're like
uh oh
cause your tax dollars go to a lot of
these schools so what are you paying for
what are you paying for somebody to come
out and be like not able that is how old
was that guy would you say tyler didn't
know how to tell time i mean that's got
to be a decent
i don't know but
seventeen sixteen seventeen going five
ten fifteen you gotta count around
fifteen percent of a hundred now i'm not
good with percents my dad's at home
watching he's like aj that's my nickname
aj don't don't be a hater because you're
not so good with the percent true but
fifty percent of a hundred you know
of a hundred is the easy one
and to say seventy even if you had a
venture guess 75
so we're in trouble as country bottom
line big trouble big big big trouble if
you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]